i'm watching these [ __ ] games on mute
or anything is special but they're the
best games first of all i think tom
brady is not gonna retire oh i really
all the evidence says he will and the
evidence says he's just upset that these
[ __ ] reporters adam schefter and
them didn't let him make the
announcement on his own that's
misinformation he's the greatest
athletes ever yes adam schefter is
misinformation misinformation m-i-s-s
information yes
but i think he's so [ __ ]
i hope he's so like combative with that
[ __ ] that he's like you know what [ __ ]
you i'm playing another season because
he always said i'm gonna play until 45.
he's 44 now why give it up now you're
still playing at a super high level big
ben retired but he's been washed for two
years yeah tom brady's still playing at
a high level the only thing i can think
is he's looking at his team he's like
we're not gonna be better next year
we're not gonna do it next year yeah
aaron's not a good enough coach whatever
the defense is getting old whatever the
reason he might think or they might lose
their offensive coordinator but i if not
i think he's like yo [ __ ] you you don't
decide when i retire you don't get to
say when i retire i'm going to play
another year
yeah well is that a scumbag move i'm
trying to understand it's not a scumbag
movie it's news now you always try to be
first so if you got the leads and your
shifter and he normally is right a lot
of people just say [ __ ] and they're
wrong shafter normally is right so i
think brady was probably going to retire
and he still probably will he probably
just didn't want to say it during the
[ __ ] playoffs and take he doesn't
seem like the guy who was like i want
the attention on me oh he needs the
victory run especially if it's a
retirement it's something like that's so
personal let the guy say to himself
versus like someone's going to be
trading going to another team it could
be a player leaking it could be a
someone in management like there's
plenty of people who can give them that
information like to do that from take
that away from him it's dirty yeah yeah
but i think he might doesn't he have a
relationship with tom like couldn't he
just hit tom and be like oh no he's
probably competing with all these other
people who have the same you gotta be
first four students
the second after he did it all of these
sites had pre-packaged like tribute
videos they'd already banked those yeah
ready to go and especially
and then you saw like their competitors
saying like well the dad is saying espn
didn't even take down i went the next
day they still said tom brady's retired
they had they weren't even they're like
bro we're done we started brady ball is
rolling [ __ ] that brady made one post uh
did you see his like insta story was
just the launch of the brady brand like
his clothing brand looking good really
like long sleeves he's a model the guy
is yeah he's a model he's perfect yeah
he's the perfect person and i truly
think he's just like i don't want to
just wait for the playoffs to be over
and then i'll make the announcement and
then it got taken out from underneath
him but i'm hoping he's like oh [ __ ] you
doug one more year 45 let's go that
announcement did scare me though because
his other brand is tb12 which is
associated with athletics and high
performance brady as a brand
that's just lifestyle that's like
michael jordan now she's like no no we
want you in like
wearing your everyday outfits yeah like
yeah i think he probably was gonna
retire i think he was done but i hope
now he's like all right let's just do it
one more time
i mean that is
an unbelievable amount of spite
i think he might have that to put your
body through that and there's no way if
he made the decision that he's pissed
and maybe he'll drag it on but like
there's no way he's going to put his
body through that's what you said all
evidence says you're right but he's also
not super beat up like big ben had a
crazy like elbow injury that ended his
season two years ago and he just didn't
look right like last year it was clear
he was done yeah you don't say that
about brady i don't manning when manning
retired he won that super bowl and went
out amazingly well because he was done
dude he got benched toward the end of
the year from [ __ ] brock osweiler so
you're looking at manning manning gets
carried to a super bowl by his defense
all right now you're done it's clear
you're done i can't think of a
quarterback at that level of elite
talent retiring when they clearly had
something left farv drug it out forever
and he was still good but he drug it out
forever you don't often see those guys
be like no i'm done troy aikman
concussions i think yeah steve young had
mad concussions these guys usually play
until they can't brady's not super beat
up body wise his whole point is i live
to maintain my body he's significantly
older than those other guys though
significantly older but in better shape
than all of them yeah cause maybe it's
pliability maybe just a freak but like
his only real reasoning was gisele
doesn't like seeing me get hurt out
there and he wants to be with his kids
you must be with his kids baby
ignore them for long enough
yeah
so who do you think wins the super bowl
i think it's the rams because this is a
mistake i made last year when i thought
the bucks are going to win offensive
line defensive line that's the match up
that's the most important right the
bengals offensive line is not good
decidedly not good burro got sacked nine
times in one game and somehow they still
won against tennessee so it gives me
some hope but the graham's defensive
line is so [ __ ] good
aaron donald is the best player in the
league on defense probably von miller
still got something left and he he got
traded there jalen ramsey is a good
corner but like their defensive line
yeah that's where i worry but joe burrow
is maybe my favorite quarterback dude i
[ __ ] love this guy yeah mad moxie
young
moxie white swagger moxie all day yeah
he's nice tonight dude everybody seems
to love playing for him he's good he's
one at every level he has he might be
the only quarterback ever to get a
heisman a national championship and a
super bowl if he wins this sunday you
know you know what's interesting is that
uh last week the conversation was
patrick mahomes or josh allen yeah and
now you're going to have to throw joe
he's the greatest his teammates [ __ ]
love him and
i grow i'm a cowboy fan right the
cowboys ownership sucks nobody has ever
since 95 has been able to overcome that
shitty organization the owners the
bengals owners suck dick too yeah they
had not won a playoff game since like
1991 or something yeah then this guy
comes along in his second year after
winning four games they won three
playoff games and now they're headed to
the super bowl like he's overcome
terrible ownership a [ __ ] cursed
franchise he did it all what makes him
so good
i think he well first of all he has he
can be accurate as [ __ ] i've seen some
deep passes where it's like jesus christ
he's mobile yeah uh he's mobile enough
to like pick up a first down
roger
he's got that escape ability that aaron
rodgers had he had one or two plays
yesterday they were sick not quite
mahomes-esque but like good yeah yeah
accurate good arm and then again i think
everybody just loves playing for me just
got that [ __ ] thing okay more than
any quarterback right now maybe he's got
that [ __ ] thing that people love
playing for this game
chase too yeah and he's got jamar chase
who he so you know when you get you know
you have a first round picked at the
fifth pick he said draft this receiver
jamar chase from lsu who's his [ __ ]
homie everybody thought that was a
stupid pic myself included i said get a
[ __ ] line because that's you're
getting killed out there you got your
season-ending injury last year from a
torn acl they listen to him they draft
this guy jamar chase and there's
literally
i don't know if there's ever been a more
productive receiver in history
statistically i have to look but like
it's like randy moss numbers and randy
moss came into the league just crazy
crazy a cooper cup
yeah
cup is good the cub's not a rookie cup
is incredible but then you do oh you
meant for a rookie i don't think we've
ever seen a rookie year like this oh
okay outside of maybe randy moss okay
but um yeah it was funny i think there's
that quote from uh from joe where he
says uh just toss it up there jamal will
get it yeah yeah tomorrow yeah yeah that
was after you had like 500 yards and six
touchdowns in one game hilarious and
they just he dude he knows how to lead
to give your receiver credit at that
moment yeah again he just knows how to
lead his defense loves him his offense
loves him he's a tough son of a [ __ ] he
takes crazy hits just gets up keeps
going yeah he used to never slide in
college i think he's finally started as
a pro yeah you guys but he was a big
ruler he's like i'm not sliding but
you think the rams got it i think the
rams got it matthew stafford is a good
quarterback he's not elite elite i don't
think but he's definitely good enough
yeah and they put so many [ __ ]
weapons around him dude that cooper cup
guy man he's insane he's incredible but
he needs credit too
stafford is yo stafford gets a lot of
people sleeping on him but i think he's
one of the most clutch qb's in the
league like when it comes to the last
drive
bro the last drive with cooper that
tampa bay game this game unbelievable
but i think something that's really
important is that like obj has the
ability to rewrite his story yes
if they win a championship yes and he
just plays well he doesn't have to be
the mvp but he just plays well all of a
sudden you forget about the antics and
also the conversation switches to he
just needed a quarterback
with og obj had a quarterback and
someone gonna get him the ball look he's
not even he doesn't even need to be the
number one on the team he don't even
have ego no he just wants someone to
actually throw the ball and help win
games and now i mean like for as an obj
fan i kind of am rooting for that right
you know like it'd be cool to see
stafford get one dog he had never won a
playoff game he'd only been like once or
twice because his team sucked him and
obj this is their first playoff wins
ever together ooh if they leave
played well he had yeah he wasn't as
good as cup but he played well i had 100
yards he had like nine ten catches
something like that amazing women lose
them after this season but but still
it's also a perfect balance because
cooper cup is always going to be the
workhorse charge it down the field and
you'll get obj those magic moments that
we know he probably likes but he's been
just doing numbers just to like help you
know what is funny about obj he did what
i probably would have done and took his
salary in bitcoin
and bitcoin was at like 60k at the time
and now it's [ __ ] tanked and his 750
000 salary is now like a hundred and
thirty thousand after taxes or whatever
yeah but he has to pay the tax amount in
cash oh yeah on the 750 he's going to
make 30 grand yeah he's going to make 30
grand antonio brown he's the same thing
right like his time i think he took it
in bitcoin and his time for the bucks
was like 30 000. hilarious and i think
uh eric adams same thing yeah eric adams
mayor of new york took him he wants to
take his like first four paychecks in
bitcoin yeah
i don't understand the point of that
though don't you just take it in cash
and buy the bitcoin because if the value
goes up you still pay for the ascended
value you don't pay the 750. yeah it
goes up to 1.5 that's what happens oh
you only pay for 7.50 no i think you
take it in cash and then you just buy
bitcoin oh okay okay yeah which is fine
then yeah it'll win that's why when
everybody goes i took my salary in
bitcoin it's like no you just bought
bitcoin okay then yeah you're going to
win you're going to find them
they get paid throughout the season so
while they're being paid throughout the
season
now they're each of those checks are
involved oh so then it will like dollar
cost average is that thing i believe or
is he saying pay me up front in bitcoin
if that was the case then he would have
got paid at a much higher rate in
bitcoin we got to get to the bottom of
this payment bitcoin [ __ ] because it
screams of [ __ ] yeah screams of just
like you're going to pay me cash and i'm
just going to put it in bitcoin it
sounds like i took my equity in bitcoin
for this podcast yeah exactly yeah
you're getting paid i just paid him
bigger i got paid in bitcoin yeah
exactly and andrew's getting paid in
sushi that's right
probably painted different things too
okay that's what it is
okay what else we got my boys all right
you want to hit a little feeling there's
no facts there's no facts let's let's
just run it quick all right yeah mr
beast
trending again number three
came out with his uh his escape room
video
and uh yeah you got like eight million
views in a day or something insane did
you watch it yeah i lost it i mean it
was just if click on this video
and shout out to his team too shout out
to tariq man we've been talking to tariq
good dude who works with them was just a
absolute beast bro 26 million make it
happen
if you click the video
and just watch the first 30 seconds we
don't have to do it now like other
people can do it because i don't want us
to get like whatever demonetized but
like you watch the first 30 seconds and
you'll just see how good they are you'll
just see how good they are creating
content that is so sticky
and engaging you can't look away the
stakes are so good it's just awesome
it's just it's just great basically they
made like the world's most dangerous
escape room and there's multiple of them
yeah that [ __ ] did a little crazy though
like there's a tnt thing that explodes
like an actual explosion in the room
yeah the first thing is literally walls
of spikes closing in on the people
while sand is getting poured in them and
there's like [ __ ] barrels rolling at
them and stuff like that like you're
sure they're not gonna die
like you can't possibly kill them but
you're also not sure they're not gonna
die you know and also you hella want to
do it yeah oh yeah let me absolutely do
this with the homies
it's basically like fear factor
escape room yeah like american ninja
warrior yeah yeah and then you just
combine them and then you basically make
escape room shots yeah
i would do that [ __ ] too that'd be great
and then the most genius thing of this
whole thing is that you didn't get a
title sponsor yeah he did it this can be
brilliant yeah or chocolate sold his own
candy bar yeah that's his own now didn't
he have like a burger restaurant or
something that they opened up is that
still around yeah i'm pretty sure it's
the thing
huh so what do you think he does you
think he like partners with these with
like a a restaurant tour and says i'm
going to use my influence to sell these
burgers you run the operations i also
think the beast was like a ghost kitchen
yeah that's what they're doing so
they're making deals where then they can
like distribute it like
nationwide through a grub hub and you
basically create like the schultz
flagrant uh kosh sandwich and then it's
just each restaurant has maybe the the
bags and the wraps and all that and it's
just uh but you still need the
infrastructure to have that you can do
it out of other people's ghost kitchens
or now they're doing it out of existing
restaurants that can do multiple yeah um
branded uh dishes yeah so it's only
delivery
i think they have a few restaurants but
i think the majority is delivered but
still it's a huge undertaking see open
even one restaurant so he has to have
partnered with someone who understands
restaurants i'm sure permits and all
that kind of stuff yeah but that's
brilliant man and i love that they're
selling their own stuff on it like
you could get the sponsor
which they did for uh the squid game
video which is [ __ ] awesome but you
could also create your own products
which you're essentially partnering with
the sponsor you're partnering with a
chocolatier is that what they call them
is it what is that exactly chocolate's
here yeah chocolatier
anyway you're still partnering but
you're basically getting some equity in
the thing that you're building yeah it's
[ __ ] awesome
rogan exactly like traeger rogan was
pushing him trigger girls and all of a
sudden they ipo he probably made crazy
money on them on it same with all this
[ __ ] yes
yes i think they sold yeah you're on
camera
he's trying to be slick there's three
cameras the food is here you just
ordered a mr beast yeah i got these
beast burgers for everybody here yeah
you just text it real quick and then you
get done on camera say what is that yeah
this is so much faster than just going
two seconds right here right here
yo can you tell me what you think about
minnie mouse not being not being
bangable at all anymore my only issue is
that it just doesn't look uh
female
and the whole point of it is to have a
female version like i can't tell that
she's minnie without the bow in her hair
yeah it's like a baby
right that's every baby like unless
there's a baby with a headband with a
bow like that's just yes
yeah and that is mice mice you don't
know what gender they are that's a good
point right but the whole point of this
is to have a gendered mouse unless she's
got heavies if she's got heavies then
i'm like oh i know what that is i don't
want fat tits for kids dude wait what do
you mean i don't want fat tits
characters for kids it's for me no this
is for kids so what do they do to minnie
mouse all right i'll show you they
basically they put her in a nightgown
not even nightcount pajamas it's a
pantsuit is it yes it is
there's a big difference they made her
divine feminine so stella mccartney
who's a fashion designer bag designer
very famous also happens to be sir paul
mccartney's daughter
uh designed the new alpha four so
instead of uh instead of this little
thing right here that little
betty boom actually in pajamas yo you
have a little sleepover i mean i'm not
gonna lie like you've got the boat yeah
the bow is what makes it feminine i
guess yeah i don't think i think that
the old outfit was trash and the
eyelashes they made they ever mad long
eyelashes and little rosy cheeks you
don't like the old fit
trash the old thing is whack yo the old
foot is dog this is like pippy long
stocking polka dots is out so bro she's
still wearing pokemon still polka dots
come on blind song jeez bro al does not
know anything absolutely um
i can't see purple yeah i don't even
like her big ass [ __ ] feet in the
shoes no that just sucks dude yeah the
outfit could have been better so smash
or pass no pass bro really pass i'll
i'll smash
might have sneak heavies though i'll
grab mickey by his ears yeah little
habit hells yeah are there any cartoon
characters you would still smash are
they most of them
no
it's just new there's only new oh you're
saying new characters that we would
smash robbie slowly get a funny quote
you said there's nothing you can do to
make telola bunny to make me not want to
[ __ ] her
i like that she's still a baddie
but yeah candace always went on fox she
was like yo they're destroying the
fabric of our society yeah why because
she got pajamas it's not even
androgynous pajamas just so we're going
to be sleeping in outside of the shoes i
just don't like the shoes
the shoes are horrible she's wearing
kanye's she's got biscuits
the outfit stinks dude let's just be
honest the outfit is not what would you
do what would you put her say again if
you could do better what would you put
her in
i would do yeah i would do this
might be legit
hell yeah show off the curves go
incredibles in this thing she got a
dumpy or what yeah she got a super dope
she's a mouse bro yeah that's a good
point they're bruising
around all [ __ ] day yeah super big
hammies
yes dude i like that i think uh i mean
she got a nice little hip sway but like
look at the dimension the feet and hands
are crazy yeah yeah yeah she's a trans
dude let's just be honest man wait what
do you mean she's 100 percent trans no i
see what he's saying just the feet and
and the hands are beating his hands oh
hell yeah bro i got that
let me see the mini version all right
all right this might be the version you
want
i mean that's better
that's better
hey yo
wait what's that is there oh she got the
dark lips bro
she's got the super [ __ ] dude you see
that look at that okay
who is that dyer is that daffy duck
duffy's girl that's not daffy dawg
daffy's a dude
yeah what the [ __ ] are you talking about
it's a duck bro it's not a dude or a
chick
i never knew about a daisy bro only duck
i acknowledge is daffy let's be serious
here i mean you know about rule 34 right
rule 34 yeah now what is that that's if
it exists on the internet there's porn
of it yeah so literally any cartoon
anything you've ever thought of your
whole life what's rule 35
we don't we've
yeah what's rule 33
i don't i don't know it's rule two i
never really got a rule 33 it's like the
bible you know i mean i know john 3 16 i
don't know john 3 17. you know there
wasn't
there wasn't there wasn't a 317. what
about 313. 313 was um uh thou shall not
bore me with outfits of [ __ ] cartoons
[Applause]
you